is this Creator a father no he is not is
he is he a trinity nope right so you
have a specific concept of the Creator
so you have to submit to what you just
described not a father in any sense he's
not a trinity he's all by himself right
doesn't be or is it begotten there's
nothing like him that's who you have to
submit to in order to be a Muslim even
if you submit to Creator and call him a
father you're still a Muslim but that's
a sin it doesn't take you out ofl you're
not no the Quran says you're a
disbeliever can you be a disbeliever and
still be a Muslim what does it say
disbel 9 ver3 it says whoever says that
the Messiah is the son of Allah is the
son of Allah is a disbeliever and
Allah's curses on on them how you doing
cens censored man can you hear me yes
are you a Muslim yep I've got a question
for you a all right where does it say
where does it say calling where does it
say that where does it say what calling
Allah sh calling Allah is sh father call
Allah father is there go okay calling
Allah father is sh because he made the
yeah yeah yeah so the reason why I made
the claim that calling Allah is Sher is
because when you say that he has a son
you're ascribing a partner to him but in
what sense you're ascribing a partner to
him so you're saying there there
somebody like him let me tell you it's
not shik and it doesn't it's a sin but
it's not sh it doesn't take you out of
the folds of Islam right oh it doesn't
it doesn't okay you want
to and nothing yeah yeah I I want to I
want to test that claim because a lot of
people have asked the question of could
anyone call Allah a spiritual father and
the Muslims have answered they've said
the names and attributes of Allah are
restricted to the text in the Quran or
the sunah and what he names himself in
his books naming Allah with names that
he does not name himself or that theet
did not name him is considered a
deviation in Allah's name and attributes
Allah says and all the most beautiful
names belonging to Allah so call him by
them and leave the company of those who
practice deviation according to his
names they will be recompensed for what
they have been doing so it's not so
whether whether you want to call it
Sherk or not it's still it's still a
grievous sin and at best at best B and
worst sh Allah something good that he
did not name himself yeah I agree with
that the point is do you understand that
Jesus drank alcohol right yep are
Muslims to allowed to drink alcohol what
are Muslims today allowed to drink
alcohol no why is that because
progressive revelation
right I wouldn't say progressive
revelation I would just say that is you
know that's contradiction that's some
things it's like at the time of AD Adam
and Eve incest was allowed but it's not
allowed today right yeah I would say I
would say that we're not talking about
the laws of God we're talking about the
character and the identity of God I'm
giving an example because at certain
times there were things that were
allowed that's not allowed today so that
doesn't prove that not Muslim are you
saying that Allah was allowed Once Upon
a Time to be called father that once
upon a time he was a father then changed
into not being a father anymore the
thing is number one what does it say
that Jes all the father well just that's
dude just answer this question Mery I'm
trying to deal with what you're saying
directly and and and to be frank with
you censored man I like what you're
doing because you're you're attacking
this head on unlike others who try to
dance around you're you're dealing with
it directly so I'm talking I'm dealing
with your reasoning okay yeah so when
you say you know like oh you know there
was some things that were lawful back
then and maybe not lawful now or maybe
forbidden now that were maybe law you
know laws change throughout time because
of Revelation I got understand what
you're saying yeah so my question along
with this is was it ever okay to
identify Allah as father I C say yes
100% to that question I would say the
answer would be no 100% through from the
Quran the Quran addresses this it says
that this is something that people used
to do in the past and to imitate them
you are imitating those who disbelieved
and that Allah's curse would be on you
and he fights against those who say such
things that's chapter 9:30 so even back
then when they did this it was wrong all
right but the thing is at the end of the
day we as Muslims we don't believe that
Jesus would Allah the father because it
doesn't say that anywhere in the Quran I
know I know that's that I know so my my
challenge is for you guys to prove that
Jesus believed and submitted to the same
God that is described in the Quran and
Islam show me that Jesus you know
believed in that particular God that's
not a father that's not a trinity you
know that's I need you guys to show me
that he believed in that and submitted
to that God did Jesus in the Quran does
the Quran doesn't believe in the Trinity
and he never father I would say that the
Jesus in the Quran is not the the real
Jesus but that that's say same about
yours as well nice so now let's get down
to the to the nitty-gritty how do you
know this cuz I'm I'm I'm asking
specifically CU I know the Quran makes
claims it makes statements about Jesus
it makes claims about Jesus my question
my or my request is to prove it verify
that this is actually what Jesus
believed this is actually what Jesus
taught this is actually what Jesus
practiced I know this because I that's
what in the Quran and I believe the
Quran is the word of God I don't believe
the Quran is the word of God I'm trying
to see if it is I'm trying to see it I'm
testing it right now I'm trying to see
if the Quran is the word of God this is
something well with with the most
historical reliable evidence that we
have on Jesus the primary sources that
we have on his life on what he taught
what he did where he lived what he how
he practiced his religion and then when
we look at these sources we see okay
yeah he actually did practice Islam or
he didn't all right wait all right can
you prove that he practiced Christianity
I can prove to you that he taught
Christianity all right because
Christianity is is to be a follower of
Christ and so that's what I can show you
that that's what Jesus taught he taught
to follow him to believe in him for your
salvation uh you know and all kinds of
stuff I can show you that I I'll show
you I'll show you one that he's not a
Muslim and then I'll show you that he
taught and spirit the Creator or not he
he submitted his will to God to the
Creator yes or no yeah he submitted his
will to the Creator he's Muslim by that
definition he's a Muslim no
against okay so if I submit my will to
the Creator yet the Creator to me is a
statute that I have in my closet am I a
Muslim no submitting your will to the
Creator is not worshiping idols
submit to the Creator is woring one God
submitting to the Creator the of your
time again again what one God I say that
the the one God the one Creator is the
idol if you but if you pray to an idol
you're worshiping idols and that's not
submitting to the Creator okay so then
so good so you're telling me that there
is a specific concept of the creator
that you have to have you can't believe
that the Creator is an idol and still be
a Muslim
so you have a specific that's fine I
like I said I believe in only one
Creator that's an idol but you can't
believe that the Creator is an idol to
begin so I'm I'm like okay you have a
specific concept of the creator that
you're talking about so for example is
this Creator a father no he is not is he
is he a trinity nope right so you have a
specific concept of the Creator so you
have to submit to what you just
described not a father in any sense he's
not a trinity he's all by himself right
doesn't be nor is it begotten there's
nothing like him that's who you have to
submit to in order to be a Muslim even
if you submit to Creator and call him a
father you're still a Muslim but that's
a sin it doesn't take you out of Islam
No the Quran says you're a disbeliever
can you be a disbeliever and still be a
Muslim what does it say you're dis 9
verse3 it says whoever says that the
Messiah is the son of Allah is the son
of Allah is a disbeliever and Allah's
curses on them says they used to mimic
the people of of the disbelievers of
your sound sucks you have to disconnect
from your car
dude you're in your
Bluetooth yeah I don't know man it's
like I'm in the with your hold on so do
you do you understand what it means to
your a Muslim linguistically yeah just
describe it it means that you have to
submit to you have to you
have let me finish to be a Muslim what
you say you to your will to the Creator
who specifically is not a father not a
Triune God is absolutely by himself
that's what it means to be a Muslim your
will to the one creator of course if you
to able to train God that's not the one
Creator well that is the one Creator by
that definition that's not but that's
not the one creator that you believe is
the one Creator you don't just like if I
submit my will to just like if I submit
my will to an idol one Idol that I'm
saying is the one Creator you're saying
no that's not the Creator it's an idol
so you're telling me that the Creator is
not an idol you're telling me who he is
he's not an idol he's not a father he's
not a trinity so these things are
characteristics that do not apply to the
Creator that you're talking about yes
worshiping an idol you're not submitting
your will to the Creator I'm with you so
all you what you have to do is show me
that Jesus submitted to the same concept
of the creator that you just gave me and
then you could if you show me that he
taught that God wasn't a father and that
God wasn't Triune and you know he's not
an idol or whatever you know basically
what we see in the Quran then I'll I'll
go with you and and submit that yeah
where did you get that from where do I
get what from that he preached um the
trying God called um what the father
where you get that from I'll answer this
by asking you this watch I promise you
this is the answer to your question what
language speak and how do you know that
from history what history just history
no what history from a Google search
where is Google get it from from history
what history bro why does it matter
because the answer to this question is
the same place where I get it from what
where Jesus taught what Jesus taught
about God where was that what's that
where do you get it from the Jesus Book
era M are you friends to the Bible are
you are you we both are all right so the
same Bible has been corrupted and
changed right the same the same the same
Bible that you rely on to know that
Jesus spoke Aramaic that's the where I
get his I don't rely on that I don't
need to know that fact oh well that you
said it's a fact yeah so so the Bible
has historical facts on the life of
Jesus yeah there's nothing wrong with
that so if it some truths in it but
here's the point here's the point if it
has since it has historical facts about
the life of Jesus then when it talks
about the life of Jesus it's historical
fact what he taught where he lived what
he did what he preached who he preached
to it's all historical fact and the
langage he did it so just because a b a
book has some facts in it that means
it's it's all true is what you're saying
I think that to be consistent you cannot
say that you accept one thing as a
historical Authority on the life of
Jesus but then reject that same Source
about the rest of the stuff in the life
of Jesus that's inconsistent you can
because it's it's not the word of God
yeah okay so you're relying on something
that's not the word of God to tell you
the language I'm not relying on that you
are I don't I don't need to know that
fact but you but in order for you to
know that fact you need to rely on the
Bible for you to know that Jesus spoke
Aramaic you rely on the Bible for that
okay for example let me ask you this how
did Jesus pray he put his head down
ground on the ground how you know that
from the Bible see so even not just the
language that Jesus spoke but how Jesus
practiced his religion there's no
problem that rely on the Bible as a
Muslim I do know there are some truths
in the Bible of course it's not all the
truth it's been corrupted it's been
you just said that this is not the word
of God yet what you how you know his
language and how you know how he
practiced his religion praying is just
form of worship that you you know how
Jesus worshiped how he practices
religion from the Bible so what it can't
be the word of God because there
contradictions and God doesn't make
mistakes the same source that you're
relying on of how Jesus practiced his
religion is how I is the same source
that I'm using to know what Jesus said
about his religion so what I don't it
has some truth of course's what's wrong
with that no it's not some truth it is
the truth it's what you rely on it's not
the truth because it has contradictions
and God doesn't make contradictions God
does make mistakes okay so then that
means that you have to leave the Quran
then where how the Quran has
contradictions bro where what do you
mean where are you kidding me I don't I
I come on I don't think that you would
admit a contradiction even if there was
one I would because it's any Muslim can
easily debunk it that way you sure yeah
you know what I'm about to change this
I'm about to say prove to me there's no
contradictions in the Quran for 2200 if
there was if there wa if there was a
contradiction in the Quran do you think
there would be Muslims right now yeah
I'm about to show you I'm about to show
you a clear-cut contradiction and I'mma
show you as a Muslim how you're going to
deny it you ready the thing is even
thing is wait even if I can't answer it
are you saying no muslim can answer that
question no muslim can answer it come on
you're L to off now why would I lie to
myself okay so when you de wait when you
debated Muslim Lon why didn't you bring
this up you brought Up's age which is
morality I have time when you had two
questions you had two questions did you
you saw the conversation right yeah so
did he actually give me a chance to
actually flush out my argument and
actually get into the conversation did
he give me a chance like he
gave ask one thing a contradiction
proves a bit wrong right no sense you're
not answering the question now answer
the question did did Muslim Lantern give
me a chance to actually uh flush out my
argument and have a fo out discussion
with him did he give me a chance like he
gave everybody else he did he gave you
two questions two questions each censor
did he give did he limit everybody else
that came up before me did he limit any
of them to two questions can I say one
thing no
answer answer limit the previous guest
before me to two questions when I answer
will you let me speak then I'll answer
the question all right he didn't tell
you why do you do you think you're going
to sit there and ask 20 questions each
you think he's got the time for that no
well well it's amazing because the guest
that he had can you ask my question ask
my question now question
now you brought a Muslim Lantern now you
now you stuck in the same bed as him no
I'm asking you you ask my question first
well I I
did you bring a Muslim you bring a
Muslim Lantern as if he was as if like
something happened there even you could
acknowledge that he did not treat me
let me speak well I am okay can I speak
ask question so so did he can you admit
that he did
not relax relax because I answer two of
your questions you're not let me ask one
question you you you only get two
questions each you acknowledge censor
can you acknowledge that Muslim Lantern
did not treat me fairly like he did the
other guests will you let me answer
please answer and go ahead and elaborate
if you want but answer directly and then
elaborate answer it directly he gave you
I'll answer it he gave you two questions
for him and two questions is that unfair
is that unfair answer my question two
questions each was that unfair what was
my question to you was yours was he did
he treat you unfair yeah did he treat me
fairly like how he treated the other
guests before me that was my question he
did not treat you unly and I'm about to
tell you why let me ask you one simple
question he gave you two questions and
he had two questions is that unfair no
or yes just between you two unfair that
was unfair yeah so you had two questions
and he had two questions you would you
like to know why if you're going to
bring up the other people before him
those other people only had one
questions each they that's not true at
all that's not true at all now see I
don't want I'm trying to refrain from
calling you a liar bro you said you
watched that live so I watched it too I
waited for a long time so I watched and
I watched how he handled the other
guests he had on 45 minute conversations
with the previous guests and they asked
a million questions and he had no
problem answering them he never
restricted them in the beginning he
didn't do any of that he welcomed the
discussion with the prior guests as soon
as I came up as soon as I came up he
restricted the conversation okay but is
answer my one question you still haven't
answer no no do you acknowledge that two
questions each of course he's not going
to be the two hours answering 100
questions for me so why was he there for
two hours answering other people's all
their questions
you're one person so no he didn't have
one person you watched that live right
you're one person I said you're one
person okay so when he had when he was
dealing with one person each yeah and he
dealt with a full topics multiple topics
a span of questions with each guest but
came to me I can only bring up two
questions and he brought up two his own
no he didn't bring up anything he didn't
bring up
anything we didn't even get we didn't
even get to my second one he cut me off
on the first one this is what he said
can you acknowledge if can't acknowledge
that he's that he was hypocritical and
he was unfair that you and I we can't
have a conversation man you got to be
honest the thing is right one thing be
honest that's all I'm asking all right
let me say one thing right you had the
chance to ask him question right you
brought up Aisha's age which doesn't you
did you brought aa's age Aisha never
came out of my mouth see that's how I
know you one question what was the about
what did you about so now we're talking
about what the debate was about instead
of Li lied you just said it wasn't about
Aisha you made a lie wasn't about what
was it there about
654 is about child marriage within the
Quran and I didn't bring up AA okay so
does that disprove the Quran why are you
asking me if that disproves the Quran
when we're talking about his treatment
of me on this platform I told you I'll
tell you let me let me this no no I want
you to be honest with his treatment of
me on the platform let me let me ask a
question right let me speak relax relax
relax my question is if you if you
brought up a contradiction that would
maybe give you another chance later if
you could be honest now you're in robot
mode